madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est avec la conviction que
nous vivons un instant particulier et
décisif de notre vie démocratique et
institutionnel que je m'adresse à vous
au nom du groupe horizon et apparentés
que j'ai l'honneur de présider
la tâche qui attend notre assemblée
nationale est considérable si le
contexte politique dans lequel nous nous
trouvons est inédit c'est avec un
nécessaire recul qu'il nous faut
l'appréhender le choix des français nous
oblige nous parlementaires à prendre un
tournant majeur dans notre manière de
légiférer au nom du peuple français
madame la première ministre les rapports
que votre gouvernement entretiendra avec
cet hémicycle devront tenir compte du
vote dont sont issus les 560 députés de
la nation
non la france n'est pas devenue
ingouvernable
nous demeurons convaincus que si les
femmes et les hommes de bonne volonté
s'organise et s'entendent au service de
l'intérêt national
alors nous ferons de cette nouvelle
configuration une force
les élus locaux que nous sommes pour bon
nombre ici font quotidiennement cet
exercice du dépassement au sein de leur
collectivité
puissions-nous nous remémorer nos
expériences et nous inspirer des
méthodes de gouvernance locale
indispensable dans nos territoires
désormais requise au coeur de notre
hémicycle
notre responsabilité collective face au
destin de notre pays mérite bien que
nous nous essayons à l'exercice
incommode mais pas insurmontable du
consensus notre pays trace sa voie dans
un monde incertain et dangereux la
guerre est de retour sur le continent
européen
nos soldats donnent leur vie pour
combattre le terrorisme islamiste et je
voudrais ici leur rendre hommage notre
situation
économique devient chaque jour plus
périlleuse et pèse sur notre dette
publique trop nombreux sont nos
concitoyens qui souffre d'un pouvoir
d'achat indigne dans un contexte
d'inflation galopante
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'europe est menacée et les événements
climatiques extrêmes se multiplient et
pour finir malheureusement la pandémie
menace à nouveau en ces temps de grands
bouleversements la france court le
risque de se retrouver en marge des
affaires du monde nous courons mes chers
collègues le risque de la vulnérabilité
ce sentiment de vertige ce sentiment de
doute sur notre destin national est au
fond à l'origine de l'inquiétude du
peuple français il nous appartient à
nous responsables politiques législateur
membres du gouvernement de les
réconcilier avec la politique
pendant cinq ans beaucoup a été fait par
le président de la république et les
gouvernements d'edouard philippe et jean
castex pour tenir le cap d'une france
plus forte plus juste et plus prospère
mais ce bilan n'altère en rien notre
conscience de l'ampleur des changements
et transition dont le pays s'impatiente
c'est dans cet esprit de continuité que
le groupe horizon s'est engagé au sein
de la majorité présidentielle qui doit
désormais devenir une association de
projets et d'actions pour continuer à
réformer le pays
ce projet de réforme porté par le
président de la république qu'on le
veuille ou non a été validé par les
français le au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
mais en choisissant leurs députés les
français ont aussi adressé leurs
responsables politiques un message rare
dans l'histoire de notre vème république
aucun groupe n'est en mesure de
gouverner seul le dialogue la recherche
du compromis et l'air large issement de
la majorité sont donc les seuls façon de
conjurer l'immobilisme nous avons
aujourd'hui la lourde responsabilité de
répondre à l'appel des français mes
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement que nous dit
cet appel il nous dit d'abord agi ses
réformes et protéger libérer appliquées
dans ces grands dîners sa philosophie le
projet que nous avons choisie lors de
l'élection du président de la république
mais en même temps il nous dit
travailler ensemble soyez créatifs et
raisonnable tirer le meilleur de chaque
proposition pour agir sur l'essentiel
cesser les postures et les effets de
manche dont nous ne voulons plus
mes chers collègues
ce message envoyé par le peuple français
nous allons devoir nous en accommoder
certes nous entendons les appels au
dialogue texte par texte c'est ce que le
bon sens politique semble commander mais
le coup par coup ne propose pas de
stratégie pérenne mûri car considérer
les choses par le petit bout de la
lorgnette n'a jamais produit une ligne
claire de gouvernement essaie bien de
ligne claire dont le pays a aujourd'hui
besoin nous sommes convaincus que le
projet précède l'alliance nous croyons
que les convergences sont possibles
notre devoir de parlementaire consiste à
identifier ces convergences à les
exposer clairement aux français et à
agir en conséquence nous le disons très
nettement proposer aux français une
plate forme d'actions communes ne
signifie pas gommer les différences
soient abandonnées les identités
politiques c'est se mettre d'accord sur
l'essentiel sur les dispositions
concrètes factuelle qui nous permettront
de répondre à la fois aux défis les plus
urgents comme à ceux des générations à
venir nous croyons au groupe horizon et
apparentés que la majorité ait d'autres
forces peuvent s'accorder sur quelques
piliers d'actions simples de bon sens et
proche des préoccupations de notre
peuple d'abord
la priorité donnée à l'éducation c'est
la mère de toutes les batailles il
existe déjà un consensus politique dans
cette assemblée pour porter l'effort sur
les fondamentaux le français et les
mathématiques pour revaloriser la
rémunération et le rôle des professeurs
améliorer l'orientation des élèves nous
donner plus de liberté aux
établissements pour mener à bien leur
projet pédagogique
prendre des mesures en faveur de
l'éducation nationale c'est aussi plus
largement s'inquiéter des conditions de
vie et d'éveil de nos enfants du
harcèlement à l'école aux violences
intrafamiliales de la lutte contre la
grande précarité à celle des
discriminations de toutes formes notre
groupe donnera la priorité à ces
urgences de notre siècle aggravée par la
recrudescence des contenus toxiques en
ligne dans le même temps nous devrons
travailler sans relâche sur les
problématiques reliées à la santé à
l'autonomie au grand âge ainsi qu'à
l'émergence d'une société plus inclusive
pour nos concitoyens en situation de
handicap
ensuite il nous faut préserver notre
souveraineté budgétaire et financière
notre dette publique se chiffre à 2008
113 milliards d'euros soit près de 120 %
de notre pib cela doit nous alerter
et nous sommes nombreux à souhaiter que
notre état soit plus économe et
reviennent sur une trajectoire
financière soutenable nous sommes mes
chers collègues que nous le voulions ou
non l'assemblée nationale qui devra
accompagner la sortie du quoi qu'il en
coûte indispensable en son temps et
restaurer l'équilibré de nos comptes
publics
nous le savons et nous le savons tous il
en va de notre indépendance nationale et
de la pérennité de notre modèle social
français les français attendent aussi de
nous une france plus sûre sur tout le
territoire de la république nous
trouverons une majorité pour mettre plus
de forces de l'ordre sur le terrain et
opérer un effort de recrutement massif
dans la justice nous devrons travailler
à la simplification des procédures pour
mieux punir les infractions du quotidien
et les violences à l'égard des
dépositaires de l'autorité publique nous
devrons consolider les bases d'une
écologie le gouvernement fondée sur le
progrès la justice sociale la sobriété
la protection de notre biodiversité et
sa durabilité
dans toutes nos réformes nous sommes
certains que nous atteindrons un
compromis lorsqu'il s'agira de répondre
à ces enjeux fondamentaux et mettre
notre pays sur la voie d'une société
sobre et prospère assurer notre
prospérité c'est aussi restaurer les
bases de notre puissance économique et
industriel c'est la france du travail
c'est une france compétitive et
innovante
pour cela il faut poursuivre la
modernisation de notre code du travail
et la réforme de l'assurance chômage
aller plus loin dans la baisse des
impôts de production pour les
entreprises nous devons atteindre
l'objectif d'un million d'ha train
d'apprendre si parents et réformer le
lycée professionnel
enfin
nous considérons que la préservation de
notre modèle social passe par une
réforme de notre système de retraite par
répartition pour le rendre plus sûr plus
juste et plus fluide nous le savons pour
le rendre soutenable ce système sans
augmenter les cotisations des actifs ni
baisser les pensions des retraités la
question de l'âge de la dette du départ
à la retraite doit être posée les
modalités notamment de prise en compte
de la pénibilité la fixation d'une
pension minimale et la sortie des
régimes spéciaux doivent faire l'objet
de discussions large mais à nouveau il
nous faudra trouver la voie de la
concorde et du compromis sur ce sujet
éducation santé ordre public sérieux
budgétaire écologie
solidité notre modèle social risques
liés à la vie hyper connectés ses
piliers peuvent constituer les sens
d'une majorité parlementaire d'action
pour faire des cinq années qui viennent
un succès pour la france
ces billets ne sont pas exhaustifs nous
pouvons également nous retrouver sur
bien d'autres sujets et surtout ses
enjeux nous devons nous appuyer sur les
élus locaux et leur faire confiance pour
ma part madame la première miss je
voudrais clairement vous dire que nous
serons à vos côtés et vous dire en tant
qu'élu de la corse suite aux propos que
vous avez tenus tout à l'heure que je
serai également avec mes trois collègues
que je salue à vos côtés pour faire en
sorte que le territoire dont je suis
issue vivre des lendemains meilleurs
comme le disait winston churchill mieux
vaut prendre le changement par la main
avant qu'il ne nous prennent par la
gorge soyons les artisans de bonne
volonté ce changement politique dans le
pays a besoin le groupe horizon il
prendra toute sa part
au père réussit à la main et au cou vous
pouvez compter sur nous madame la
première ministre merci